Now that we know that each time this loop here runs, it puts at least 1 vertex from the minimum
vertex cover into its solution, what can we say about the running time of this algorithm here?
As in the previous unit, we can express the running time actually in 2 ways.
We can either use n, the size of the input, or we can use k,
which is the size of a minimum vertex cover for the input graph.
So when you run "Take 2" on a given input of size n,
and where the size of a minimum vertex cover is k,
how often is that loop here executed?
Does the loop run up to n times? So up to the number of vertices times.
Does the loop run at most k times? Or does the loop run at least k times?
Please select the correct answer here.